- You have to have your schedule so,
you really have to plan your day well.
And I always like to make
some thing different.
At least, different from myself.
I always follow my heart with what I do.
- [Audience Member] Do you have a routine,
do you work out every day, what's the?
- What's the deal, what's the deal?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- I'm actually a robot.
Everybody needs to
develop their own thing.
I don't really look at other people.
(trance music)
- Hello Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn
from one of the greatest
DJs of all time, Tiësto, and my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number four is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also as you're watching
if you hear something
that really resonates with you
please leave down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within the first
couple hours of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(inspiration music)
- I mean it depends,
if I have some time off
I always take time for music so,
for me it's different I think
but when I'm touring everyday,
I have actually more routine
than when I'm not touring everyday.
So you have to have your schedule.
You really have to plan your day well.
But if I have six weeks off,
I'm pretty much all over the place.
Yeah, you don't really have a schedule
so you just do whatever.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and you waste time.
- Yeah, but if you have a
really military schedule
then you have to really
plan everything well.
So that works better for me, actually.
I run 2007-2008 after I released my
"Elements of Life" album and I felt like
you know I've been
playing this kind of music
and DJing this kind of
music for so many years.
And I was just like, I want
to try something different
because I felt I had everything done
that's possible in the trance
world, where I came from.
So I could keep on going making trance
but then they all start sound the same
as everything I've done before.
And I always like to
make something different.
At least different from myself.
And to push myself, I always like to
yeah look for the next thing.
And I moved to L.A. for a couple months
and I heard the American
DJs play there and in Vegas
and they were mashing up all the stuff
and everything was possible.
You could play like a dance
track and a hip-hop track
and everybody loved everything.
That inspired me to
become more open-minded,
to really get more influence by
different styles of dance music.
And that's where I become more like
the "Kaleidoscope" album, more like
loose rock indie artists,
singer/songwriters.
And try to make different kind of songs.
- [Interviewer] How has it been?
How has the journey been for you?
- It's been a rollercoaster journey.
And yeah, it seems like
it's never ending, you know?
Every year I think maybe
now it's going less good,
but still everything is going great.
I always seem to make the right
decisions at the right
time so far, in my career.
I always follow my heart with what I do
and with the music and so far so good.
And I'm just happy with everything that's
happened to me in the last ten years.
- [Audience Member] How do you keep
your energy and your health,
every time I've seen you all these years,
you have such...
energy.
Life has ups and downs,
you have break ups,
you have business problems.
Every time I see step on to that stage,
it's like do you have a routine,
do you workout every day, what's the?
- What's the deal, what's the deal?
(laughs)
I'm actually a robot.
(audience laughs)
Born in space.
But I think it's very important
to just have the passion for it.
You know, and everybody can see that.
I'm just a real person
and I love the music.
I love to perform, I love to
DJ, I love to talk about it.
I think that's, if you love what you do,
you'll never really get tired.
I think that's the most important thing.
I think the new generation
DJs is very clean,
very focused on their work
and focused on their careers.
And you can't afford to do drugs on stage.
For me that's always
the exception, I guess.
The Amy Winehouse of
the DJs somewhere but,
I think in general it just
doesn't work like that.
People, DJs know they have one chance,
and one chance only so they have to
make the most out of it.
Yeah, you can't let that go to pieces.
So it's just about being a good DJ,
it's about the right music.
Fight for every chance you get.
I made it to the top and nobody
can ever take that away from me anymore.
So I feel less pressure
and actually, I been
number one two years in a row.
So that's even more crazier, and I'm like
well if I'm not number one next year
I'm still going to be a good DJ.
No matter what you have,
no matter who you are,
always try to be yourself.
(record scratch)
I want to do something special,
because everyone always says well,
the DJs are the new rock stars.
But in general, they're
still just playing clubs,
and do whatever they want
and not really put out,
put in a good show, so we had some
Brazilian drums, some Asian guitars
and for me that was the most
incredible experience I ever had as a DJ.
In general, I like to
work with people who can
bring something creative
and emotional value
to the song so it doesn't really matter
if she's or he's famous or not,
it's more like what extra can
he or she bring to the song.
That's, to me, the more important thing.
No, not really pressure but you know,
everybody needs to do their own thing.
I don't really look at other people
or what they do, I don't
compare myself to anybody.
I just want to make myself
the best possible show
that fits me and fits my crowd.
Lately more and more
people struggle, I think
in dance music because
they're not creative anymore.
I think too many people
just think commercially,
only about money and not
try to innovate the music
like they used to do even
three or four years ago.
(crowd cheering)
- I can't wait to get in.
That's why I'm here this early,
to get a great spot in there.
- We're from Luton.
- Luton.
- Everybody here's from Luton.
- Okay so you only come
here to see Tiësto?
- Yep.
- We've been looking forward
to this for two months.
- [Crowd] Tiësto! Tiësto! Tiësto!
- He has the greatest
club set in the world, so.
- We love him.
- We love his bravery.
- I never expected this, so I think
it's going to be really
good vibes tonight.
- [Crowd] Tiësto! Tiësto! Tiësto!
(crowd cheering and screaming)
- Hello and welcome to Copenhagen.
We are now standing in front of Parken
and we are going in to
see a fantastic concert.
- Bandspotter.com, I like it. It's good.
(trance music)
- How is it to stand like one man
in the middle of the crowd,
like it's really gone to the moon.
- Yeah.
- You came from nothing
and then you're just like
standing with your hands in the air.
- I'm the American dream.
- (laughs) Yeah but how does it feel?
I mean, I can't imagine.
- How does it feel?
- You don't get shy or
anything before you start?
- No, you get used to it, I mean not
in the way that it's not exciting anymore.
If you play for thousand
people or five thousand
or ten thousand, it
doesn't matter anymore.
You know, it's a lot of people.
So you get really excited,
I mean it's amazing.
To be there by yourself
and you play your tracks.
- Okay, I can imagine that.
(Line laughs)
It's the biggest rush on earth.
(trance music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video this video because
Mark Syria asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in a future Top Ten,
please check out the link
down in the description below
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Ranya Rahim.
Ranya, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book "Your One Word"
and posting about it on Instagram.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.
- You can't plan the future, you know?
You never know what's going to happen
but I just decided for myself,
as long as I really enjoy it
and don't see it as work I will continue.
And as soon as I feel
like now it's getting
boring or annoying then I'm
definitely going to stop.